you know with this whole pandemic a lot
of broadcasts are getting [ __ ] up with
technical difficulties i got a list of
them
anyway so last november the anchor guy
craig melvin
threw it to the reporter named
kendallenian but delanian had lost his
connection with the control room didn't
know he was still on the air and here's
what happened
nbc's ken delanian has some new
reporting on something that we talked
about
at the top of the hour uh ken what have
you learned sir
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay uh i think we lost think we lost
kent for a second we'll try to get him
back there
i like that the anchor guy instead of
saying whoa he obviously doesn't know
he's on mike he goes
i think we lost him there no you didn't
lose him
clearly if we heard he said [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
on a recent episode of the five greg
gutfeld didn't realize the show was back
from a break
time now for one more thing i got a p i
got a p s you're on the air
great greg
jesse why aren't you saying you kicked
us off it would have been great if you
didn't know the mic was on instead of
singing like he said something like
really
non-fox news like you know i have to pee
but trans people should really be
allowed to use the bathroom too
i wouldn't mind you sharing my bathroom
with a trans person
right that would have been embarrassing
on fox news saying
singing you have to pee isn't so
embarrassing our buddy uh george takei
he got booked on cnn to talk about a
serious topic the rise of violence
against asian americans
but every time he started getting into
it something kept buzzing during the
interview
after the bombing of pearl harbor this
xenophobic
hysteria swept across the country and
that hysteria
reached even the presidency of the
united states
and i don't know what it is with
this is there we go uh sorry bob nice
save
here it is again something's wrong with
this what is it like for you personally
i mean obviously you're famous you're
well known sorry
brad something's wrong here
perhaps we can go back to you george
poor george
poor brad right away it's like brad then
you know brad was so nervous he walked
into the frame naked with a wrestling
helmet on
from sunday's activities
and then you know how when you use zoom
you always have to tell someone you're
muted
and ceo mike taylor is with us to talk
about how they can help eliminate
airborne and surface pathogens including
covid19
hello there mike
can you we have you muted right now mike
is there any of this that you see is
anything other than trying to
prevent people from voting
i think you're on mute joining us now to
talk more about it is michelle streeter
with
she's the vice president of
visitmesa.com michelle thanks for being
with us
all right we're going to move on maybe
we can get michelle back coming up here
in just a bit
everyone is suddenly their grandmother i
don't know how to work this
oh this is unbelievable meteorologist
elena lee she features people who send
him pictures of their cats
during the forecast okay so somebody
sends in a picture
of a cat named kittler
and the cat has a hitler mug all right
so if you're working at a tv station
and you see somebody sends you a picture
of hitler and he's got a hitler mustache
you right away go i can't put this on tv
this is a fantastic that's not cute
this is kind of weather for the cats so
we've got our saturday night forecast
for you now where
we are featuring kittler here thanks to
debbie alexander
and i think hitler kind of looks like
charlie chaplin here so i don't know
maybe we're going to call him charlie jr
but anyhow the weather's going to be
great
i guess the phone's lit up immediately
right like hey
that's not charlie chaplin it's hitler
by the way you know what was good about
this story what about five minutes later
the cat got adopted by mel gibson
least he found a home his owner says he
killed six million mice
how lovely is that anyway she got on the
next day and she apologized
last night i didn't make a mistake
during our caturday segment
i used a submitted photo of a cat with
an inappropriate name i don't want to
use the name here but i never intended
to hurt or offend anyone by using that
picture that was actually just given to
me
i understand my mistake and i'm deeply
sorry and in the future
i will absolutely be more diligent with
this content to ensure it never happens
again
i wonder when she found out see i want
to know the back story
like what happened there could be a
movie in this
that's right